and you're explaining it to fans here
with me for the very first time right
true exclusive for the alley
interference fantastic you know the
Outlander France notice every little
detail and on the season three deleted
scenes they saw the tiny sea that was
carved on to Jamie's hand it was
remarkably actually a tiny J on clears
hand let's talk about that and where
that might have gone yes our sharp eyed
viewers are at it again
essentially with there's a scene in the
book and actually in a different book
where Claire and Jamie carved their
initials into each other's hands I think
in the book it was in the second book
right before she goes back through the
stones we did not do that in season two
but it was one of those little details
that we kept thinking at some point
we're gonna do this so he shot a version
of the scene for season three but we
weren't really satisfied with it didn't
really work so we cut the scene but we
wanted to sort of still preserve the
idea of doing that at some later date so
we didn't include that scene in the
deleted scenes for the DVD
however sharp-eyed fans found the
initials in a separate deleted scene
that we had not have gone in and
digitally erased so it's like curses
what was your reaction when you found
out that that scene had been cut from
the season you know I think I was quite
quite excited for the fans to see that
because they wanted it from from before
but no you may make an appearance
somewhere else and that happens all the
time
you know there's so much that we shoot
that doesn't make it to the show and you
know we can't include everything you
know that happens a lot you know things
we shoot a lot of stuff that doesn't
make it into the final edit a lot to be
honest I don't think the scene quite
what's in the story and where it was so
yeah they made a great decision and I
think it's difficult sometimes when you
try and shoehorn something into another
moment but you know it's also a fan
favorite so we do try and do these
things for fans and so you you always
have to find just something that works
and and it has to work for the story
actually it's kind of fun I mean you
know it's I hope they know that it's
something we really want to do and and
while you hope you don't have those
wealthy
happen on the other hand it's kind of a
fun little tidbit for people the scenes
and recognize that people are actually
really watching I didn't know that we're
gonna put it somewhere else but I guess
they will so we'll see it then we'll do
that scene again who knows maybe you'll
see somewhere else maybe Jamie gets a
see carved on his toe or something next
season I don't know Joe very nice
[Music]